the dawn of VR is upon us and now that
the price specs and requirements for the
PlayStation VR the oculus rift and the
HTC vive have been revealed you might be
wondering which one is right for you the
first thing you should probably look at
is price Sony's headset is the cheapest
of the bunch which comes in at around
four hundred dollars on the other end of
the spectrum is the vive which is 800
and finally you can get the oculus for
$600
but the headset isn't the only thing
you'll need to buy obviously the
PlayStation VR requires a ps4 but you'll
also need to pick up the PlayStation
camera for 60 bucks and if you want the
full experience you'll probably want to
get two PlayStation Move controllers
which are 50 apiece if you already own a
Playstation 4 then all this will
probably cost you around five hundred
and sixty dollars not including taxes
sony announced that there will be a
bundle at launch that will come with the
playstation camera and one move
controller but as of now we don't have a
price but even with all that PlayStation
VR is still cheaper than the oculus rift
the oculus rift is retailing at $600 and
it comes with a sensor integrated
headphones an oculus remote and an Xbox
one controller but once again if you
want the full experience you're probably
gonna want to pick up the oculus touch
controllers which as of now don't have a
price and won't launch with the headset
then there's the HTC vive this one is
the most expensive of the three for $800
you'll get the headset two wireless
controllers and two sensors besides a
compatible PC which is a hefty price in
itself the HTC vive comes with
everything you need to experience VR
right out of the box if you're wondering
what constitutes the price difference
here is where you'll find your answer
the resolution for PlayStation VR is
1920 by 1080 across two lenses or 960 by
1080 per eye while the oculus rift and
vive have a resolution of 2160 by 1200
or 1080 by 1200 per eye all three of
these devices use OLED displays and the
vibe and rift both have 110 degree field
of view while the PlayStation VR has a
hundred degree field of view one area
where the PlayStation VR comes out on
top is its refresh rate the vivan rift
both have a refresh rate of 90 Hertz
psvr on the other hand will have a
maximum refresh rate of 120
Hertz however one big difference between
PlayStation VR and the other two
headsets is that PlayStation VR will not
have a tracking area this means that
unlike the vive and oculus playstation
vr will not track walking movements the
vive will allow a 15 by 15 feet tracking
area and the oculus will have a 5 by 11
tracking area finally before you take
the plunge into VR you're going to want
to make sure that your rig can handle
these devices if you're leaning more
towards PlayStation VR all you need is a
ps4 the headset will also require an
external processor but that comes
packaged with the device but if you're
leaning more towards the oculus rift or
the HTC vive things get a bit more
complicated
both headsets will require an nvidia gtx
970 or AMD r9 290 or greater graphics
card in an Intel i5 4590 processor or
better you will also need at least eight
gigabytes of RAM for the oculus and at
least four for the HTC vive both
headsets will require an HDMI output and
USB ports the oculus will require four
USB ports three of which need to be USB
3.0 and one which can be USB 2.0 the
vibe on the other hand requires one USB
2.0 port if you don't have a PC capable
of running either of these headsets
oculus website can point you in the
direction of some oculus ready pcs the
oculus rift comes out March 28th and the
HTC vive along shortly after on April
5th if you're holding out for
PlayStation VR then you'll have to wait
until October
what headset are you leaning towards let
us know in the comments below and for
more VR stay tuned to game spot